ducey has the story tonight live from
the north lawn good evening peter
good evening president biden likes to
talk a lot about how colvin 19 and mask
wearing are not
political issues but a key part of his
response team who also led president
trump's
response dr anthony fauci just made some
very
political observations about biden
versus trump
one of the new things in this
administration is if you don't know the
answer
don't guess just say you don't know the
answer the idea
that you can get up here and talk about
what you know
what the evidence what the science is
and know that's it
let the science speak it is somewhat of
a liberating feeling
fauci was standing by as president biden
signed
10 more executive orders that makes 27
orders or actions
in just a day and a half and more are
coming
especially related to covet relief
our national strategy is comprehensive
it's based on science not politics
now that he's president joe biden is
going to throw the book
at covet 19. it's 198 pages
and getting fema involved in the
response may sound familiar
this is a model we use to respond to
hurricanes
hurricane sandy which i was deeply
involved with biden plans to use the
defense production act to spin
up materials to make vaccines but he
admits he can't stop the spread alone
asking the american people to mask up
for the first hundred days the next 99
days
although biden did not adhere to an
executive order he signed yesterday
mandating masks on federal lands when he
spoke at the lincoln memorial
on federal land i will give my all to
you
why weren't president biden and all
members of the biden family masked
at all times on federal lands last night
if he signed
an executive order that mandates masks
on federal
lands at all times he was celebrating
an evening of a historic day in our
country
president biden has long claimed
republicans will have an epiphany and
jump at the chance to work with him
the republican leader of the senate has
seen early moves on immigration and
climate change and now
the president can and should refocus his
administration on creating good paying
american jobs
not sacrificing our people's livelihoods
to liberal
symbolism president biden isn't changing
everything though he plans to keep
christopher wray
as fbi director there are some people
christopher wray as an example i'll just
bring him back up who will continue to
serve in his role
and he didn't like the idea that he
might not be thinking big enough
thank you guys far higher that's
basically where the u.s is right now
when i announced that you all said it's
not possible come on give me a break man
good start to get on that track this
country needs to vaccinate one million
people per day
and in the state dining room dr anthony
fauci got there before biden so i asked
him how far away
are we from the 1 million a day and he
said
starting now you're going to see that
brett
peter ducey live in the north lawn peter
thank you